I'm really excited to welcome
my dear friend, a mentor
now, like align to Google.
So happy to be here. My God, it's
uh, Nellie's really, I truly
a force to be reckoned with.
She's one of the first Latina
producers in Hollywood,
former president of
entertainment at the [inaudible].
She is the Latina Tyler Perry.
She's got a day and a
really excited today.
She's a media mogul and on
a mission to empower others.
And so I want to take
a chance if it works,
we're going to play a little sizzle reel
that will just tell us more about her
journey. So really important for
us to show that because again,
I would not be able to do a
Nellie's journey justice, uh,
in terms of all that you've accomplished.
So, uh, that collection of your stories,
absolutely amazing.
And what we're here to talk and to talk
about today is self made. So it's a,
her entrepreneurship manifesto that
is a New York Times best seller. Um,
so really applaud you for that because
there are how many Latinos that are
bestsellers
for Latinas histories and three
of them are dead celebrities.
And I think we have to understand that
the New York Times is a big and be having
a New York Times bestseller is very
hard to do a, you have to sell x amount,
you know, so many books.
It's a lot of books.
And so we have to be able to buy things
in mass together to reach those numbers.
Right.
For me it was like climbing
Mount Kilimanjaro and very
important to me because
how thought leaders are made in
America are through the New York Times
bestseller.
I have to say that the day that I met you
and Indiana who I love her from Google
as well.
Um,
we had an event together with women of
Silicon Valley with Sheryl Sandberg.
And then I had you ladies
because I was so proud of you.
I said I felt like a
proud mother to see you.
How beautiful and smart and I was just,
I mean he laid it to have you and that's
the day that I decided to write self
made. Wow. Because Sheryl Sandberg and I,
she had asked me to do an event.
She knew that I have a big constituency
of Latina multicultural women.
She wanted to do an event for lean in.
And I had a very long talk with
her before and I said, Cheryl,
I'm happy to do this event with you,
but you have to understand that the book
is not that relatable to multicultural
women. So many of us have had
paths that are not linear. Right.
And she was, she was wonderful. And
you know, we had, you were there,
we had a very feisty conversation
about it and I'm a big fan of hers.
But that day I thought to myself
as she was speaking, I thought,
who's going to tell our stories?
Who's going to tell the stories of women
like us that are immigrants or the kids
of immigrants or who have had detours
or women that are Muslim or African
American or Asian who really come to
this country and reinvent themselves and
are emerging in countries around the
world. And I heard in my ear, you do it,
you do it. And then of course sometimes
our low self esteem shows up and goes,
can't take it. I skipped the
way it is. What do you think
you are? And then I said,
if you don't do it,
who's going to do it?
And I and I did it and I'm very
proud that I've spent a year,
140 cities around the country meeting all
kinds of women and really uniting with
not just all multicultural women,
go with white women realizing that,
and we now know after the whole election
that this is an incredible year for all
of us and that we need to talk
about this issue. A lot of power,
power that we don't even know we have now.
Tell us what is self made?
What does it mean to be self made?
So self made?
It's so wonderful to be in a tech company
and talk about self made because it
doesn't mean you're going to leave your
job and go be an entrepreneur tomorrow.
It also doesn't mean that especially
all of you in Silicon Valley,
that one of you is going to go off
and be the next Zuckerberg. You know,
these are one in a million situations.
But the good news is sub meters a mindset.
It begins by thinking like
an owner in what you do now.
You're not going to leave your job.
You're going to think every
day that you're in business
school working for other
people, using other people's money and
sitting there every day and saying,
if this were my company,
what would I do?
Would I spend this money and make sure
that you let your bosses know how you
feel.
You're practicing being an a founder
and an owner and if they don't listen to
you,
that's fine,
but you have to every day come
into work not thinking victimized,
thinking like an owner.
The future for all of us is to
think and behave like owners.
Then we have to think that self made
is a mindset and it's a mindset of
understanding that the United States
works on a premise that most of us don't
know. The premise is that to
make it to the end of your life,
you have to make money while you sleep.
Which one?
One of my billionaire bosses and
mentors told me that I was like, you're,
it sounds like a foreign language.
I didn't even know what that meant.
That meant that the money
you make at whatever job you
do, whether you work here,
whether you're a doctor or a lawyer,
if you just count on the money
you make and the money you save,
you're not going to make
it to the end of your life.
So entrepreneurship isn't just
becoming a founder or a maker,
it's also being someone that makes money,
saves money.
Sometimes you have to do it by starting
a side hustle and that money you save,
you have to invest in like me real estate,
which we'll talk about.
That's why I said don't buy shoes by
buildings or invested in stock or invested
in buying an existing business and let
other people run it while you have a job
or supplier diversity where you understand
that there's a lot of contracts in
corporations and in the government that
are ear marked for women particularly
and multicultural specifically.
And guys,
if you want to make money partner with
a woman and a multicultural woman and
you'll do better that we understand that.
Whether you're an entrepreneur
that leaves your company or not,
you must think entrepreneurial
entrepreneurially from
this moment on in your
life to make it tell us,
tell us about it,
Nelly at age 12 where did this come from?
When did you become self made? When did
you get this entrepreneurial spirit?
I think for me it all began in the
seventh grade. I think for so many of us,
sometimes our greatness comes from pain.
I was the kid of immigrants.
We had no money. My parents came from
communist Cuba. They lost everything,
including their degrees. They had to
start all over. I became the hero child.
I had to help them translate for them,
do everything.
And in the seventh grade we were having
a lot of money financially for our
struggles.
Financially.
I was an all girl Catholic school and uh,
basically I would overhear my parents
saying, what are we going to do?
What are we going to do? My father and
my mother would say, Cameron was, I said,
and my dad say, don't
worry, Jesus will help us.
And I realized that I had
to go help my parents out.
And a lady down the street,
an older Jewish lady sold
Avon. And she's like, honey,
why don't you sell Avon and you
get some free lipstick? I go,
I got to cut a better deal.
And I went and said to her,
I will sell Avon in school,
but I needed to be 50 50
and I started making money,
200 bucks a week selling Avon,
paying down my,
you know, my, my entire tuition.
And then having the nuns sent home a
letter to my parents so my dad wouldn't be
upset that if I was paying
down the tuition and I
brought it home and my mother
goes, what does it say? And my father
goes, your daughter is a genius.
And Jesus helped us after all.
And I think that was the beginning of
the Aha that if there's a problem we can
fix it. There's no point in
being a victim. We fix it.
And I think that life is a series of
those issues that maybe for some someone
else is a catastrophe.
And for me it was like the beginning,
the beginning blocks of my,
you know when I'm Beyonce talks
about her persona, Sasha fierce.
I mean there is, I am like a Latina
immigrant from New Jersey who's kind of,
you know how sometimes self esteem
issues show up and I don't feel good.
And then,
and then I created a persona and I'm,
I got my own version of Sasha fierce
going on. I'm like, I'm a beast.
And it happened brick by brick step by
step learning that no one else is smarter
than us, that it's a matter
of being louder and braver.
This is not a country of wimpy people.
This is not a country of not understanding
the constitution and the First
Amendment and not understanding that
you have rights and that we're all very
much part of this country and our
voice needs to be heard. I mean,
don't you love seeing a Latina
on mainstream TV defending women,
multicultural women and Latinas?
Why do we feel like we can't do that?
Why do we marginalize ourselves in small
situations when in fact we have all the
power in the world. Latinas
in this country are the
number one emerging market.
That means we are the number one
consumers in America together with African
American women, Asian women, Middle
Eastern women. If we unite together,
there is no company that
can survive without us.
So how do we not put that information
inside our bodies and become empowered and
know that we have all the
power in the world? We take
ownership, we are self made.
That's right. That's right.
It's a mindset shift.
Now, there was a moment in
your journey when you were,
you were working for a corporation and
you realized at that moment that you were
acting like an owner,
but you really weren't enough.
Can you tell us?
So I got into television,
um, very early on.
I was lucky because I wrote an article
to 17 magazine about why you should never
send your kid to all girl Catholic school.
And they published it and it was a
biggest guy on the low and my family.
And as a result, um, 17
magazine offered me a guest,
the youngest guest editors ship
in their history. Um, so again,
that's when I learned it doesn't
pay to be wimpy, speak up.
And I got into 17 magazine,
which led me to television,
which in my wildest dreams I would
never have done. And very early on, um,
I met, I, I, you know,
in television I was interviewing a lot
of people and I met a gentleman who was a
very big producer in Hollywood and he's
like, are you Latino? What are you?
And I said, yeah, I am. And he said,
I just bought the first
Spanish TV station in America.
And he's like, why don't you come
and work for me? And I go, excuse me,
I work for CBS.
Why do I want to work for some
Rinky Dinky Spanish TV station?
And he's like, I'm rich. Are
you rich? He goes, young lady,
what would it mean to be employee one
of a business that's going to be a
multibillion dollar business?
And I was like, oh my God,
that's how he sounds a
little smarter than me.
And I think that was my first attempt at
not really thinking anymore about what
is my career path,
but who are the people that I'm going
to follow that are smarter than me.
I went in at 22 years of age,
ran, I was the general manager,
the youngest general manager in the
country of the first Latino TV station,
which is now that I'm on now, but back
then it was an independent station.
I killed myself. I thought like
an owner. I work 24 hours a day.
I had no personal life and three years
later I walk into work and they had sold
the company and I went to see my boss
and I said, how could you do this to me?
This is my baby.
And he's like,
and I'm crying and bawling everything
they tell you not to do and he's like,
stop young lady. Those are my
chips. If you want to play,
go get your own chips.
And that is the moment I had to
mourn that I was losing my baby.
And then I said I have
to start my own business.
And so I started a business at 25 making
TV shows or that's what I thought I was
going to do.
And for four years I did not make a penny.
So I did the, I would tell you the
opposite. Do not leave your job.
Don't just go bootstrapping without
knowing what you're going to do.
I have a whole formula for you.
But I did that.
And can you imagine that Latino parents
put a five on to find the hottest band?
You're losing your logs.
And four years later I
was like praying to God,
Dear God, what if I bought to throw me
a bone? Everybody thinks I'm a loser.
It was not cool to be an entrepreneur.
Then my all my friends were like, dude,
can you get a job? What's your
problem? And in the fourth year,
I got invited to a chamber
of commerce event and I went,
and I always say in life, if you
show up, maybe something happens,
maybe nothing happens, but if you don't
show up, nothing happens. Guaranteed.
I went and I started asking people
what's wrong with my business plan?
And they said immediately they were
like, your business plan's wrong. Wow.
There is no pipeline for your content.
There's only one station you need to go
build the pipeline in the distribution.
So I switched my business
plan to launching TV channels
around the world for big
companies.
So it was supplier diversity in a way.
So I basically went to work with Fox,
HBO, Espn, Sony,
and I would take their brand
and launch it in Latin America.
They would find that it was my business.
So if it's screwed up,
they could get rid of me easily.
It was my own business.
And then I launched it separately
and I launched 10 channels that way.
And then the original TV station that I
ran was bought by an American insurance
company and they had bought a bunch of
stations and they didn't know how to run
a Latino network. So it went
into bankruptcy. Sony bought it.
Sony was my client.
I had launched,
their channels are abroad and I was
the only Latina that they knew that had
fiscal responsibility for large
entities of theirs abroad.
And so they basically
offered to buy my business.
And offered me the presidency
of entertainment, which
is running the network.
That's the creative job in a network.
Um,
and so I ran Telemundo for four years
and I went back into corporate life.
So I understand very much becoming self
made as an intra entrepreneur and as an
entrepreneur outside of a corporation
and both ways is very important because
only in a corporation do you
learn how to scale something? Yes,
I think we're all learning that.
I think even myself,
I've, I've, uh,
myself and Eliana who's here have coined
ourselves as like the entrepreneurs
creating and seeing opportunities
where they don't exist. Now tell me,
so you mentioned your mom at one point,
are you and your parents were saying on
the way you need to get a husband and
you mentioned in your book that there was,
there's no such thing as prince
charming or princess charming.
Well I think that's,
it is a bigger idea then then.
Then even how I say it,
I say there is no prince charming and I
don't mean that against guys or anything.
I think there's no prince
charming for any of us.
I think the idea that a mate or a boss
or a corporation or a government or a
president is here to save us is false.
I think that when you
work for other people,
you think often think whether
you're a man or a woman,
my boss is going to see how great I am
and give me the big promotion and your
boss has their own problems in their
personal life and in their business life
and sometimes the company you work for,
I mean you guys are
lucky that you're like,
I was in an emerging field at the time
and you're all in an emerging field,
but companies go through ups and downs
and they really are not worried about you
and so it's not.
It's really about changing your mindset
from a victim and thinking that any job
is good or bad to,
I have to make whatever job I
have under whatever circumstances,
a lesson, a learning lesson to
this puzzle that is my life.
That little by little,
all the puzzle pieces are going to
make sense because you are on a journey
that's going to take you somewhere.
We're all the puzzle pieces
are going to come in handy.
Now,
speaking of changing mindsets,
so one thing that I really related to it
in your book was how the notion and of
our relationship with fear and failure,
especially as the Latino community,
I think we oftentimes
are more risk adverse.
So what can you say in terms of kind
of what you've written in your book,
advice to us to change
mindset? So I think, you
know, I think my book,
I really wanted Latinos to see
a Latina and not just Latinos,
everybody to see that a woman of color
with speaking about money and power,
very important and that, and then a Latina
woman would say in a book, I want to,
I always want it to be a millionaire
and not from a place of greed because in
our culture it's being rich
in every way that matters.
But from a place of knowing my power and
knowing that it's possible and knowing
that that's why we came here. But what
gets in the way of that for all of us,
at least for me,
fear and fear of failure,
it happens every day of my life,
still every day of my life.
So what I say in the book is that
to make it to the end of your life,
you have to change your relationship
to fear and failure. And for me,
I've had to turn fear and failure
into my best friends. You know,
fear shows up every day and it's a
real thing. It's a feeling and the,
and what comes up for all of us, which
is human, is runaway, runaway. Go Away,
don't do it.
And for me,
and all of you in the tech
world know that a brain,
just like a computer can be rewired.
You have to rewire your brain.
You have to tell yourself, I
tell myself every day, okay,
fear shows up. My color, I,
Shashi, and I go, okay, you're
telling me I have to do it, do it,
do it, do it. Anyway. When
my book was coming out,
my dream was to have Susie Orman write
the foreword to my book as a woman of
Color,
the only person I had ever year as a
woman talk about money with Susie Orman.
I was obsessed with her and I wrote her
this magical email. I barely knew her.
I met her three times,
but she wasn't my friend or anything.
I wrote her a magical email and I was
ready to send it and I and my low self
esteem showed up. Kids will
pick it, I get the ladders.
Who Do you think you are like as
soon as he doesn't have time for you.
And I was like,
do it anyway because I've wired my brain.
I say it to myself every day. Do it
anyway, do it anyway, do it anyway.
And I went back
and five minutes later Susie said,
yes, I'll do it. Now that doesn't always
happen, but if you don't do it anyway,
maybe 50% chance it'll happen.
50% it won't. But you got
to keep doing it anyway.
And then my other thing was,
you know,
in our culture failing is like the worst,
which we know in silicon
valley it's like high five.
We felt right I five next because you're
around the corner from the answer.
But we're not raised like that. So my
other biggest fear was fear of failure.
And I have failed. If I
showed you my failure tape,
we'd all be crying right now.
I have failed thousands and thousands of
times to win three times in your life.
You better be failing thousands of times
or you're not going to win three times.
And that's all anybody remembers.
So what,
how did I rewire my brain around failure
when I failed so many times in my
personal life and my business
life and my finances fail?
I've had to say to myself, okay,
cry it out, cry it out, go mourn,
and they get back on the horse, get back
on the horse, get back on the horse.
Because if I don't pull myself out of it,
around the corner from my greatest
failures had been my greatest successes.
And if I didn't wait,
it wouldn't have happened.
So that's very important.
Yeah, I think oftentimes I've even
faced that where it's, I call it,
I call it the imposter syndrome and that
we bring with us like in our everyday
lives, US questioning if we should be
here. And especially in the tech industry,
there's this large conversation that we
all hear everyday around diversity and
the lack of diversity.
And so us killing the imposter syndrome.
And I've also said like, I leave that
girl at the door, let's talk about that
diversity and imposter syndrome because
I feel like the diversity is such a hot
potato and I think we need to blow
it up because diversity to me,
the way we've, oh, and
especially I'm than you.
So I grew up in a whole
other world of diversity.
I think diversity means somebody is
doing us a favor and I think we need to
like, like, like blow that thing up.
Because the truth of the matter is when
multicultural people are about to become
the majority in this country and
very by the year 2022 number two,
when multicultural women are the
number one consumer in America,
the answer is we're doing
everybody else a favor.
And if the company doesn't
look like all of us,
it will sooner or later fail because that
means you have no relationship to your
customer, the number one
customer in the world period.
So you really have to take that in.
So somehow we've told ourselves
a story about diversity below,
not wear it up because we are lucky.
They are lucky to have
us because we represent.
Then there are a number one customer.
So let's not ever think that again.
I love it.
Now how is it that you and your book,
you talk about you and in
order for you to be chosen,
you have to choose yourself
first. That's right. How do you,
how do you go about that?
Tell us.
Well, if I ask a man, you know, as
someone who worked in television,
cause worked in television for many years,
I cast a lot of people and let's say I'm
casting a cooking show and I go up to a
man and I say, well what do you do? Oh,
I'm a chef, I've been a chef for them.
I'm an award winning chef and maybe
they just started six months ago.
If I say that to a woman, uh,
you guys go, Oh, you know,
I'm a real, I kind of can cook really
well. I go, well, are you a shot for,
are not a chef Tom?
If you don't declare yourself,
how am I supposed to give you
a, you know, an opportunity?
I think that we have to forget.
Humility is a beautiful thing except
at work you really have to declare
yourself. You have to say,
you have to know who you are,
know what you're good at,
and say it and call it out and raise
your hand and show up at events and speak
up. That's where Cheryl's right.
You have to lean in, right.
And I think to not understand that
we live in a world of loud people.
This is a loud country.
It does not pay to be [inaudible] and
all that and that's why I tell everybody,
I'm going to just tell you right now,
I could never,
as a Latina from New Jersey and my
grant with my humble parents have raised
millions of dollars from my businesses.
If I didn't go and take acting lessons,
I recommend everybody take acting lessons.
It's Super Fun.
It's a great way to meet people that
you want to date and it's going to serve
you very well in life because
I'm super introverted.
You would never know that,
right? Super, super introverted,
but I've had to cultivate an extra,
you know my,
my Sasha fierce side and I think that
you do it by pretending you're someone
else in a character. You
know, every time I've raised,
I made believe I was my old
Jewish bosses that were like,
if you don't give me the money,
someone else is going to,
you're going to miss the opportunity.
I can even get into their voice and I,
when I spoke inside their body,
I would get money. I go, man,
this stuff works.
So I want you all to think that we
can't all be good at everything.
Cultivate these sides of us.
In order for me to sell TV shows,
even though I was an introvert,
I had to go and pitch the show
and make people excited about,
I had to cultivate a sales persona.
Huh.
Now going to, so it's noisy.
You mentioned noisy earlier,
which brings me to another point.
You said you to make an immigrant,
you're a role model,
which I think is a really interesting
point because in today's political world
to say that I think is,
it's a strong statement.
It's a statement that I
think is beautiful, but maybe
some other people may have.
Yeah.
Well I think,
I think everything that I am
is because I'm an immigrant.
I think it's my superpower. It's my, it's,
it is my secret sauce because
immigrants of which, you know,
80% of CEOS in America, immigrants, by
the way. So that should tell us something.
I think that immigrants come to this
country and are super patriotic.
We've come from a place where something
bad has happened and we are grateful to
be here and we are hard working.
We're willing to do whatever it takes.
We're willing to still bootstrap.
Yeah. And do whatever it takes.
And on top of that,
we have an incredible value system that
I don't think people realize, you know,
uh, the other day I spoke at the FBI, I've
spoken at the military, you know, I'm a,
you know, you wouldn't think that
of that Latina Latino immigrant.
I cry at the American flag.
I cry when I'm around the military.
I loved being at the FBI the other day.
I am proud to be an American
in this country. And I have,
my mother always said to me,
you have the best of both worlds.
You get to be Latina and passionate
and colorful and eat Latin food.
And you get to be fully American. And I
think that says it all. So when my book,
I wrote an entire chapter,
think like an immigrant and follow,
make an immigrant.
You're a role model.
You will not go wrong because immigrants
are leading the life and the and
they're holding the values
that we've lost in this country
and talk to us about. So I majored
in finance, um, as an Undergrad.
So I've always been really intrigued
because I felt like growing up,
coming from an impoverished background,
I wanted to make sure that I
understood how to manage money.
That was like my important thing.
We don't have a lot of it.
Let me ensure that I manage it well.
Um,
and in your book you talk about the
hidden money in America and in your home.
That was eyeopening.
Yeah. Thank you. I think that's,
that's the big secret in the book.
I think first of all,
I always say math doesn't lie.
You know, I am very blessed because
I've always been pretty good at math,
but I didn't really like it.
And when I went to work at channel 47,
I realized I couldn't read financial
statements and I hired a math tutor and I
realized that it was,
I was very good at math,
but I had been taught math incorrectly.
And so I say that because so
many of us are afraid of math.
Math is super creative and
fun and I believe that why
I've been successful in my
TV life is because I've had a real math
head because math is very important.
Um, in the book I talk about the hidden
money in America because this is one of
those things in this
country that we don't know.
There are so many opportunities that your
taxpayer dollars offer you and yet it
doesn't get marketed to us.
So we don't know that there is billions
of dollars in the federal government,
in the small business administration
and the Department of Commerce,
there's it and the Department of Commerce
that we could apply for and then start
a business tomorrow with
their it that they funded.
There is money for not
just to fund your business,
but also to buy a building,
you know, to buy a building.
Every entrepreneur should at some
point try to buy the building.
Their businesses in the building will
be worth more than your business.
Eventually,
this real estate that Google is in,
eventually it will be worth
more than Google. I promise you.
So there's so much money there.
There's so much money in supplier
diversity in every corporation in America,
and that means contracts that are
designated for women and minority owned
businesses first. Now, if we don't
apply, other people can apply,
but why are we not applying when there's
a million nonprofits in America that
help you fill out the paperwork and
teach you how to do it? There are grants.
People talk about how there's
no money to start a business.
There's so much money in grants at every
nonprofit in America for starting up
businesses that we don't even know about.
And so there was all this money that
everybody says there's no money out there,
but it's just that the, the information
hasn't gotten to you. So what happens?
A lot of white guys in corporations find
out about this money because they have
consultants in Washington and they go
find a woman or a minority to front a
company and they go get the money. Why
are the rest of us not doing that? Again,
lack of knowledge,
lack of understanding the system of this
country where we have to make money.
While we sleep,
right,
I'm still working on it and that we all
the becoming self made and even being
millionaires is not some elite thing that
is only the lady that started spanx or
Zuckerberg or these one of a kind unicorn.
People know if I,
that started as an intern,
went to an assistant, worked my way
up, made no money for a long time,
started really making money at 32
invested every lived beneath my means.
Even at 32 when I started making money,
I didn't go buy a lavish car or a house.
I started buying commercial real estate
using the tax laws of this country.
$5,000 flip the buildings
kept flipping the buildings.
10 31 exchange,
which is a thing in this country that
allows you not to pay tax on your earnings
if you keep flipping the money forward
and buying more real estate and buy 45 I
work because I want to and not because
I have to, which means I could retire.
Now retiring is very different
if you live in Bentonville,
Arkansas than if you
live in San Francisco.
But all of us can do it.
Not from a place of grandiosity,
not from a place of being a founder,
not from a place of being an inventor,
but like a turtle like me.
One step at a time.
Deciding you're going to do three
things a year, every Sunday,
three things every week to get to
the three things a year, every day.
Three things to get to the three
things of the week, like a turtle.
Slowly you win the race,
so don't buy shoes by building.
Absolutely.
Do not go for instant gratification
because you're sad or you feel bad or
whatever.
No,
because you're going to get
over that purchase in a week.
Have a big dream. I wrote down when
I was 20 I want to own a house,
not own a mortgage on a house,
own a building on a business,
have a house in my,
in my country of origin,
which it's not going to be cute bus.
It was going to be Miami and I have it.
I want to retire by 65 I got to my
number at 45 without being j Lo,
Beyonce, an athlete or Mark Zuckerberg,
none of the above. And I still made it.
So what is everybody else's problem?
If I can do it,
all of you can, should and will
do it. It's only a matter of time.
That's right.
So tell me,
did you have a mentor in terms of
real estate or, great question.
Well,
I'll tell you this,
this is in my book to everybody thinks
a lot of people come up to me and they
say, can you be my
mentor? I go, me, I'm on.
I don't have enough hours in the
day to be everybody's mentor.
I'll tell you this,
I have Atlanta mentors,
but not one of my mentors
knows they were my mentor.
So when I found people that
I thought were super smart,
I would stay late and hang out with them.
I'd volunteer,
I'd read everything about them,
everything I would go to,
every event they spoke at, I would write
down everything they said and what I do.
And I really think this works.
You know,
for those of you that are very young
listening that are in your twenties go to
50 cars to you that's old age
to those of us that are older,
go to 80 85 start looking at people that
are the oldest you think they can be
and start making a composite person of
everything you love about somebody there.
You know,
we're all human.
We have good sides and Beth and you can't
find one perfect person and that's why
people get disappointed because they
think they're going to find everything on.
One person forgot about it.
You see this person over here and you go,
I like the way they've dealt with money.
I liked how they live in old age.
I like this person,
how they deal with family.
I like this person's spirituality and
make a composite and make a picture of it
and write down everything you want and
go to 85 or two 50 of you're in your 20s
and work your way backwards.
I did it to 50 and I saw all these people
that I want it to be and I got to 50
and now I'm thinking about 85 or 90 or
even a hundred cause I plan to live a
very long time.
All right now to,
so three pieces of advice in terms of
making money in our sleep. Oh, easy.
Number one, do not leave
your job. Number two,
lower your overhead. I have to give
you more than three. Number three,
start a side hustle one hour a week
and you're not cheating on your company
because if you're not doing this,
you're not bringing anything
back to your company.
You need to be out there doing
the shared economy. So ladies,
clean out your closets
that Kingston yet I drives,
whatever you don't want one hour a
week south, something in your house,
start there and put that money away.
Everyone should have a compound
interest account in the bank.
I always tell if you're 20 something
and you put $5 a day away in a compound
interest, you will be a millionaire
by 50 so let's just start there.
One hour a week, side hustle, put
the money away, lower year over it.
Start.
It's,
it's really fun to watch money grow
when you have two years of money,
say two years of salary.
One one of those years is for a rainy day.
The other one is your investment fund.
I want you to think what you don't all
have to be entrepreneurs that create
businesses. What are you going
to invest in real estate?
I mean immediately especially, I mean,
how much is real estate gone up here?
Crazy. Okay? If not,
look at a little business
down your street.
Some old person that's going to retire
and their kids don't want the business.
Pick something that already exists.
Don't invent something that is for
the one 1.111 percentile franchises.
Do you know what the number one franchise
in America is right now? Tutoring,
buying a franchise is like if
I had to do my life over again,
I'd buy 20 franchises,
I'm gonna make my kid of different sorts.
But if food, Yoga, tutoring, whatever,
I mean they give you the color by number,
how to do it,
why does everything have to be so hard?
You saved some money,
put it in and the thing
makes money while you sleep.
So there are many,
many,
many ways to become self
made and we all must do it.
Even if you work in a corporation,
you have to be an entrepreneur and
you have to be cultivating your
entrepreneurial self made life.
Looking back, uh, what are, and I
think I know the answer to this,
but what is your most
proudest moment looking back?
Well two things.
Obviously my son that I gave birth to,
which I don't even know how
I did that cause you know,
I didn't know what I was doing,
but my parents are very happy about that
and I have four step kids. So I'm very,
and I wish if I had to do my life over
again, I think I'd have more kids.
Cause I cause I,
cause I think that's a great part of life.
And then my other do realize that when
my time clock was ticking so hard that
no,
but I realize it now.
I realized it in the last few
weeks because my son is leaving,
this is his senior year in high school.
And I'm like,
why didn't I have a few more
waiting behind this is to me, no,
I left home and love my mother. They're
crying. What if I bought, don't leave.
And I left. And now I feel
like man, Karma is a bitch.
But my other proudest moment is that
I started in television and I started
college and I dropped out because
I got so many jobs in television.
And you know,
really at that time an emerging field,
my life experience was really valuable.
But I always wanted to go back to school.
And I really felt as I got older,
like there was real gaps. Um,
not just in my education because
my business education was,
I had gotten it in other ways,
but my emotional intelligence, uh,
and my ability to read people and my
ability to do other things. And so my,
my second proudest moment is that
I took a four year sabbatical,
which for a type a workaholic
is very hard to do.
So that I only did it when I felt like
I had enough money, you know, to do it.
And I went back to school and I got
a master's and doctorate in clinical
psychology, which I'm very proud of
so that I can be all your shrinks.
And I don't think I would have written
this book had I not done that because I
had to go back to school. My first
professor said, you write like a rapper.
And I was like,
because you know,
I was in TV where they were like pithy
little marketing things that I wrote and
he's like, here's Strunk and white,
learn to write all over again. And I go,
I love this.
And I ended up writing 97 papers
and a thesis and a dissertation.
And I don't think I would've had the
discipline to go back and write this book,
which I had done after going to school.
Okay.
And tell us what's on the horizon.
What's next?
Well, I have been on a, as
I said, 130 city book tour.
I first need arrest and I think my
priority for the rest of the year,
it has to be the rest of the year and
into next early next year is first of all
to analyze what I've learned on the road.
I've met so many men and women,
I've heard,
I feel like I've been Hillary Clinton
for a year, you know, city by city,
by city meeting all kinds of people.
And I really want to analyze that
and figure out what to do with that
information, like a good entrepreneur.
But also I want to focus on my son.
It's his last year of high school and
I really want to be there for him and
really help them out.
And,
and then I'm very open to all new things
because I think the number one thing
that I would say is important for all
of us is to evolve and grow every day.
You know,
there's so much that I know now and so
much that I've mastered and yet so much
that I don't know.
And I think that we all have to wake
up every day understanding that we know
nothing at all.
And I think when you think like that
magical things happen to you and you're
open to new ideas,
new possibilities.
And I'm right now sitting on two years
and a book where I did so much research
of knowledge that I have to now spend
the time to take all that, you know,
research and development that I've done
and figure out what do I do with that
and any advice,
we're for the Latinos here at Google
and just in the tech industry.
I know you're going to be meeting
hundreds of more Latino's.
What do you think that we
should be thinking of and
what can we be doing more of?
Well, I think, I mean
I've said this before,
but you all have to be louder and braver.
It kills me to have everything that's
happened this year and to have my African
American friends say, why are you
Latino so quiet? Why do you take it?
And I,
and I understand why we take it,
cause that's how we were raised and it's
our parents baggage. They're afraid,
but it's your all of your jobs to
not carry that baggage with you.
You have to know there's
nothing to be afraid of.
No one's going to do anything to you.
It's all BS. Nothing's going to happen.
On the contrary.
And I think that the best advice I can
give you is sometimes I understand that
we may,
you know,
although I believe the answer for all
of us is uniting with all the other
multiculturals and learning from each
other because we all have different traits
and different skills.
I understand that sometimes let's say our
voice can't be the voice of an African
American sister who was very empowered
and very strong. Maybe that's not us,
but what you can,
one of our super,
super powers is we're
very vulnerable people.
And so sometimes when someone says
something in front of you and it's really
like not cool, sometimes they
don't even mean it. It's just they,
it's their learned wiring and behavior.
You have to say something like, excuse me,
what did you just say?
You just stabbed me in the heart.
That was so painful to hear.
That is so,
that is so hurtful. And that's just
as strong as saying, excuse me.
There's many ways to
skin the cat and be loud.
Maybe it's not always being loud.
Maybe it's being honest and vulnerable,
but we have to speak up.
I don't allow people to say things
about my culture, not in public.
And by the way,
you don't think I was afraid to go on
Fox News knowing that they were going to,
I broke out in hives, but I did it anyway
and I didn't die. You know, there was a,
there was, I said a few things and
about immigrants and they, you know,
I on social media, people were
like trolling me like crazy. I,
so what the next day it's over.
You're not going to die.
Nothing's going to happen,
but you're going to gain character and
there's something that no one can take
away from you when you speak
on behalf of your family.
That's beautiful. Um, I want to make
sure that you get any last remarks,
but I also want to see if anyone here and
the audience has questions for Nellie.
This has been my, uh, magic moment
at Google having you here. It's been,
it's been awhile. We've been planning
this. What? I'm really, yeah,
they're so proud of all of you. I
in Ileana. I'm so proud of you too.
Love you guys. Um, yeah. So
I'm wanna hear questions.
Don't you guys want to know
about Donald Trump? Okay.
So I'll just tell you a quick celebrity
apprentice story cause I think you'll
enjoy it. So I, you know,
when I ran Tele Mondo,
we sold it and NBC gave me a
very big deal to produce shows.
So I produced about 700 shows
in English and Spanish. I,
that's why I say I'm Tyler Perry Latina.
Um,
and I get a call one day
from NBC and they said,
we want you to be on celebrity
apprentice. And I was like, well,
I produce reality shows. I'm not in them.
And they said, no, we really think, uh,
the president of NBC said,
I really think you would be great
because Donald Trump is tough.
And we think if we put a
Latina actress or something,
he might really insult
them. And you know, you're,
you've worked for six billionaires and
you've had them as clients and there are
a lot worse than Donald Trump and take
it, you can take it. And the truth is,
I've had to take it, you guys, I've worked
in Hollywood, I have been yelled at,
screamed at,
I've had people be very disrespectful
and I had to like not take it personally
and put people in their place.
I had to go into my other persona.
So I said, right. And they go, we're not
asking. You were kind of telling you.
And I was like, but I'm not
a celebrity. They're like,
why don't you just say thank you for
millions of dollars of publicity for your
personal brand? And I was
like, okay, thank you.
And I went on celebrity apprentice
and in the first episode,
Donald Trump yelled at me.
And in the first episode I did what I
would've done with any of them have you
saw me on the show. I would very
respectfully, because I didn't do it like,
you know, as they say in Spanish
and I go to, I'll say that, no,
I would do it very like, I'm
sorry, but no, I don't agree
with, you know, we're not,
you know.
And we got into these very
feisty conversations and
after the first episode when
we were off camera, he said to me, Oh, I,
it's so great that you yelled back
at me how great. Keep doing it.
We're going to get a lot of ratings.
Latino's are love you because they don't
like me and it'll be great that you're
yelling at me. And um, and that
tells you a lot about him. You know,
like he loves to argue for sport.
And he was very into the ratings.
And very much the value of his property.
But I actually,
um, had a great time on
celebrity apprentice because
I was partnered up with Gene
Simmons from kiss. And you know, when
he's not being the guy from kiss,
he's like a Jewish dad. He was very
lovely. And one day he says to me, Golan,
you're,
you're such a smart girl,
but I feel like you're always climbing
a mountain the hardest possible way.
Like you're, you're struggling like
an immigrant that just arrived.
And I thought it was like he,
he was like stabbing me in the
heart because I thought that's true.
Sometimes there's Latinos.
We don't even know how to enjoy
the journey if it's not hard,
if we're not struggling,
if it's not climbing a mountain
the hardest possible way.
And so I've given a lot of thought to
that and I think what I need to work on
the rest of my life, because God
knows I'm not a baked cake, uh, is,
you know,
achieving things with ease
versus struggling so much
having to suffer so much to
make things happen.
The quick question on
curricular real estate,
what's the biggest lesson learned or
like the hardest thing that you had,
like figure it out?
Well, I think, you know, I did,
I did find mentors in real
estate as well. Um, my,
I have a mentor in real estate,
her name is Elaine and she's 75 years old.
And one of those people that I met
that I just thought she was brilliant,
she was developing real estate and I
started taking her to dinner and to this
day she is my mentor. I don't buy a
building without her. Um, I mean at all.
If she doesn't, okay. The building,
it doesn't happen because as she has
taught me very well in real estate,
it's all math. And I have to
tell you something in my TV life,
the reason I've made,
so I've made five times the money
in real estate than in my TV life.
And I think it's because my TV
life is creative and emotional.
Sometimes I've made bad judgment calls
because I fall in love with the show.
I don't fall in love with buildings.
If the math doesn't work,
you don't buy the building period.
So there's something about mission and
money having something in your life that
you love and that's, there's nothing wrong
with that. But why? Until you're rich.
As the,
as my boss told me,
the money part has to take precedence
because you only, you have,
oh so many years of life,
force of energy where if you're
doing five things at once,
I don't feel sorry for you because you
have a lot of energy later in your life.
You're not going to want to do that. So
to me, yes, you have to find mentors.
You have to go go to events like this
because if that's something that interests
you, that is, that is a
path that works linearly,
slowly,
all the tax incentives and all
the tax laws are in your favor.
Hence Donald Trump. When he says,
I don't pay very many taxes,
he's not lying.
That part is true.
All of us can pay lesser taxes if we
follow the tax laws and invest in things
that give us all kinds of benefits.
Your new role, someone in the last
five years? Well, I'll tell you my,
my, my role model that I, that I
think about most often. I have a few,
but I love Gloria Steinem because I love
Gloria Steinem at 85 she is beautiful.
She is really deep and profound and like
peaceful and yet she's still doing her
work. She still shows up
and speaks and all that.
I also had a professor in
school who was 80 at the time,
82 so she's now 85 who had gone back to
school at 50 after raising five kids had
become the world's foremost expert on
Sigmund Freud has written six books on
Sigmund Freud and now she travels all
over the world lecturing in her expertise,
which is sigma for it.
And at 82 she looked like she
was 50 and I thought to myself,
and then she really inspired me in
school to find what is my True Path.
There's a lot of TV producers,
but what I thought that I offer the world
uniquely is from a multicultural voice.
I really walk the walk of
an entrepreneurial person
of a self made woman.
I've done,
I've sacrificed what you need to sacrifice
to get to my age and be self made and
be sad and I felt like it is my duty
and when I saw Sheryl it concretely was
clear to me.
It's my duty to pass that on obviously
first to my Latinas because I love you
guys and I want you all to succeed.
Then then two other multicultural women
and men and then to to all young people
because I don't want everyone to think
that you have to be that one of a kind
unicorn person that makes it big
when all of us can do it. As I said,
like a turtle.
I know we're going to be doing
a book signing after this,
but I want to thank you again
for Nelly Golan for being here.
Joining us for talks at
Google in collaboration with
all our Google's Hispanic,
Google or network and talking about self
main New York Times bestselling book,
becoming empowered,
self reliant and enrich and everything
rich in every way. That's the
key. And why are we doing this?
To pass the torch to the next generation
of a mindset that is self reliant,
that thinks like owners,
that multicultural people particularly
think like owners and everything.
We do. Thank you. Thank you.